i did that i did that what like two
years ago
and you could tell nutty professor was
your favorite movie yeah that's the jam
right i know
it bro yes bro
yes bro yes cause you're doing
all the characters yeah man and i it's
like when i was doing i'm like that's
what eddie murphy went through man i'm
like i feel
you know it i might not been on the
eddie murphy level but i'm like
i can do it yeah you're doing no one you
know you're doing it man you know so
once a big old budget come in and you
got some big people who want to like and
that is
you know because even that looked legit
like oh yeah
it was good very well done it was good
yeah i had fun shooting it you know so
how important is production quality in a
social media post
oh it's big it got to be clear you can't
shoot with no android
it's not going to work take that
androids it's not going to we're
watching this on android just shut it
off because your whole life is shut down
please
please don't i'm sorry you know android
it's not a no it's just not built
i iphones are built for chats yeah it is
built for shooting and editing
it is it is androids are built for
suckers i guess
even though i have an android i got an i
got a galaxy s6 actually
oh i'm waiting on these sponsors to come
through man i need i need an apple
sponsor
[Laughter]
eventually right yeah it's one step at a
time most definitely yes yeah
patience because if you can and that's
something important for
like um a comedian that maybe is posting
sketches
and it is on an android as opposed to an
actual like camera which now people are
shooting cameras
shooting skits on like red cams and
stuff like dslrs like it's that
professional now yeah
that's that's oh that's phenomenal but
it's important i think for somebody
starting out or
just on the hustle and all they have is
an android still still do it yeah don't
don't let that stop you
do the rest yeah don't let that stop you
yeah cause you never know they
i know it's a camera but you probably be
funny is it you know what i'm saying
exactly don't worry about that you know
what i'm just saying we're just talking
about the quality
exactly you know so use what you got
yeah
don't let this believe if you can do
more with less you get more
most def you can do everything most
definitely oh i like that quote
i like that yeah you can do more with
less
when you get more you can do everything
most definitely or more do anything
yeah yeah that's that's the team
yes i don't steal it that's what he said
yeah that's what i loved and watching i
watched the desi bank show and i was
because i knew you were a fan of eddie
murphy and martin and like mike epps and
all this and then seeing this production
i'm like
yo like i i knew who you were before
before doing this interview but i always
like in-depth research my guests and
when i started looking into you
i was like oh whoa this isn't just
somebody who's funny on instagram
this is someone who has actually built
a platform really like a media company
is what you've done in a very short
amount of time
yeah is that what you're seeing in the
long term like a tyler perry
studios type oh man i would love that
that you see that that's very inspiring
i can see that i can i can see it
you know i can see it
i can see it you know but like i said
with
stuff like that i'm pretty sure like you
know tyler p
he had like a team of people that did
their job man
and you got to have that you know
and god let's not forget about god you
know and
no more dick nobody forget i'm sorry i
just love hearing interviews like i gave
it up to god yeah just keep thinking no
more
yeah but yeah yeah
everybody got to be doing a job there's
only so much a person can do
yeah by himself because there's so many
talented people that's out there
but it's like they need that
extra help man like you need that x you
got it you need that
like i don't care like you need that man
you need that team you need them people
you need that people doing their part
you know everybody doing their part
thanks for watching hot breath the verse
if you want to support the show
go join our patreon but if you don't
like supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click the watch more videos to
keep us alive in the algorithm hot
breath